era o fim da linha para o começo
quer entender o fim de qualquer evento
circulação relação olha para como tudo
começou
isso ensinaram as minhas anciãs e foi o
que eu fiz para resgatar uma vida
enrolada na infelicidade em fevereiro de
eu decidi abandonar o meu lar e ir viver
na incerteza nos que se disse muito
escuro de lado estava a esconder do
mundo
sentia-me partida eu não tinha
conseguido ser aquilo que se esperava de
mim uma mulher perfeita
bem casada toda certinha que eu sentia
muita muita vergonha
o problema da vergonha desaprender brown
é que ela ensina sobre a nossa
identidade
sobre aquilo que nós pensamos que os
sons tipo você nem nada
você não é ninguém é diferente da culpa
porque a culpa tem mais a ver com
comportamentos algo que supostamente
fizemos de errado mas eu forcei entanto
para fazer parte do mainstream da
sociedade
estudei maningue falta de empregos
viajei pelo mundo mas eu sentia que algo
não estava bem aqui dentro então uma
conversa com o amigo estava desabafar a
falar de mim como vítima da vida ninguém
teve entenda
ninguém da minha bondade me escutou me
escutou escutou mas depois disse inna eu
acho que tu não valoriza a coisas que
nos dizem eles caem como uma luva só que
ela era uma nova muito apertada
eu não gostei eu tinha com valorizar e
os outros
fiquei muito zangada fiquei doente você
imaginar o que as pessoas queriam pensar
de mim naqueles mais 30 anos de vida
eu não valorizavam e foi isso que me
impulsionou a procurar ajuda por todos
os caminhos onde eu passei
esta poltrona da minha psicóloga até a
sala de aulas como cidade de
desenvolvimento pessoal
eu confio no time com as seguintes
questões o texto quando vende como é que
estava a viver a sua vida a forma como
estava a viver a sua vida dá prazer e
satisfação é amável e o que está
disposta a fazer a viver uma nova
realidade
então é sobre isso que eu venho falar
hoje quero falar de como é que o sexto
as questões para inventariar o meu
presente e meu passado e criar uma nova
realidade para minha vida
mas o que o inventário um inventário
pessoal é um método de cirurgia que
apoie as pessoas a responderem perguntas
simples que expõe aspectos importantes
sobre os seus valores e os princípios ea
sua o seu modo de vida entretanto que o
trabalho uma forma mais ampla que eu
quero partilhar convosco que é abrirmos
completamente a nossa vida e começarmos
então por primeiro percebermos quem é
que nós pensamos que sons hoje histórias
o evangelho é que nós nos colocamos a
nós próprios
hoje ea seguir o que nós fazemos é
tentar perceber qual é que nós possamos
acreditar nestas coisas o que nos
aconteceu
deixe lá nem fácil para nós acreditarmos
em coisas que nos fazem bem
e finalmente no inventário nós temos uma
opção temos opção e aceitar mudar vou
continuar a viver da mesma maneira
então eu pensei essa viagem
queria entender
primeiro que eu sou ensinaram me que eu
sou um ser divino criado à imagem e
semelhança de uma força
iná não sei onde mas se não tinha nada a
ver com o que eu pensava que eu era
havia coisas básicas como por exemplo
ajudar o próximo e eu já não sabia se eu
fazia porque era gentileza genuína ou
estava a fazer para tentar agradar as
pessoas
eu precisava de se frear essas questões
eu queria perceber onde é que eu me
perdi na minha biografia interior
claro há pessoas que dizem que são águas
passadas
são águas passadas sim mas se o curso do
rio não muda
nós vamos passar pelos mesmos obstáculos
por isso é que me atrevia e fazer essa
viagem então fui à minha infância desde
o útero da minha mãe pois isso é
possível se é possível a uma
psicanalista brasileira chamada joana
filha
kan fez os seus estudos que o feto
memoriza tudo o que acontece com a mãe
durante o período de gestação
comigo o que aconteceu é que durante
todo o tempo de gestação a minha mãe não
estava contente
então eu já vi o mundo para fazer rolar
feliz
depois fui viajar um pouco pela minha
vida como criança na minha família muito
barulho muito conflito do poder entre
pais e filhos muita escassez de recursos
e um recordo que então de seguir para
não me envolver com medo de me envolver
eu iria oferecer a todos para fazer os
mais velhos com dentes
eu pensei em tudo até paraty contato com
as minhas próprias vontades
depois viajei pra minha vida na rua com
criança e que eu me recordei foi do
bullying é que eu me sujeitei
semanalmente senão diariamente usavam
porque não sabia brincar às cenas das
crianças porque é clarinha porque tinha
pintinhas na face e depois entrei na
adolescência problema adulta e pensei
refletir sobre as três são james
manipulações desonestidade linhas e dos
outros
e o que eu percebi o inventário é que
consistentemente eu existia e será
boazinha sempre disponível
como falava sempre os meus sentimentos
para não incomodar os outros tinha medo
de ser rejeitada
um aspecto importante desse inventário é
que nós temos que chegar um ponto de
assumir a responsabilidade
estamos conscientes que nós é que
criamos as nossas ou a nossa realidade e
quando nós assumimos a responsabilidade
nós também percebemos que nós educamos
os outros
como é que se devem comportar nas nossas
vidas mas é claro que isso não é fácil
na infância
ninguém nos ensina os nossos pais nossos
familiares não tiveram isso na sua
educação
muitos deles vieram de sistemas ou
princípios familiares políticos
eu sei que eu e muitas pessoas aqui da
minha geração não sei quantos anos eu
tenho mas viemos de famílias onde se
ocultavam segredos platais para a
família e para a comunidade
mas como nós somos adultos nós temos que
assumir a responsabilidade pelas nossas
vidas
e foi isso que este inventário pessoal
trouxe pra mim foi um momento de pausar
e assumir responsabilidade do resto da
minha vida
este inventário as domina a perdoar né
ea perdoar os outros
ajudou-me a resgatar o amor por mim e
pelos outros ajudam a definir claramente
qual é a minha visão quais são os meus
princípios e por onde é que eu quero ir
e por isso que eu partilho convosco para
que ele compôs para também tentarem
inventariarem as nossas vidas o vosso
presente ou passado e reformular as
nossas vidas mas é uma coisa importante
eu também quero deixar aqui que é muito
importante nós agradecemos por todas as
experiências que nós tivemos
se não fosse por tudo que aconteceu na
minha vida talvez eu não estaria aqui
tudo que nós passamos juro foi pra nos
moldar e serão essas pessoas que nós
somos hoje
e aquele perguntas vezes mas sim isso é
difícil
tudo leva prática e podemos fazer muitas
coisas para interromper os diálogos
negativos que acontecem dentro de nós e
hoje eu gostaria de partilhar convosco
uma forma tão simples de fazer e se essa
interrupção que você já conhece permitem
ok então peço que coloquem as vossas
palmas das mãos
esta parte que costa gente cujas mãos na
center diretos
o que nós vamos fazer é uma coisa que
vocês fazem os dias que é inspirar o ar
segurar e depois vamos tirar todo o ar
pela pouco inspirados
segure tiramos pela boca
parecendo que não acabamos de
interromper um diálogo interior e é isso
que eu faço isso e mais outras coisas
hoje eu já vivi uma vida mais honesta
mais autêntica e mais íntegra e tragos
também pra vocês
vamos deixar a pirataria social e vamos
viver vidas mais autênticos mais
verdadeiras e hoje quando venço
congratulo quando o erro
o rijo e continua a viver a minha vida
então são essas palavras que vos deixou
hoje sequer entender o fim hora para o
começo e ram co
meça obrigada
[Música]
[Aplausos]